[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
oh
tuesday
[Music]
we're getting closer and closer
to knowing the truth
what happened on january 6
when the cheeto dust mobster
tried to [ __ ] on our constitution tried
to overturn
our vote
with the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt
we are only days away from the very
first hearing
that is now we're coming to find out
that it's going to lay out
the entire narrative and the entire plan
from start to finish
for the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
it's going to be about a 90 minute
presentation apparently
and fox news
fox news is scared of the truth
tucker carlson sean hannity
laura ingraham sarah laura ingraham
and she could be a karen too i don't
know
all are terrified of the truth of what
happened
when their orange mussolini jesus
tried to overthrow your vote
then throw it in the trash get rid of
our democracy
forget about democracy we want autocracy
and they're scared of the american
people even their viewers knowing the
truth and that's what it tells you folks
that is what you should know
about fox news and all these [ __ ]
trumped up fascists
their objective
is for for their viewers
their supporters to not know the truth
that's why we look at them and go why do
they keep lying why do they keep lying
they're liars that's because
if their viewers knew the truth they may
not have viewership
i mean
if a bunch of people don't believe a
bunch of fascist ass [ __ ] who's gonna
watch the fascist
who's gonna tune in to the fascism the
traitor tv cable networks
i mean if he told the truth if steve
bannon told the truth and how much of a
[ __ ] bag he is and how much he hates
american democracy how much he hates
america and how hard he worked to
overthrow it so they could have a
fascist state
i mean he's basically saying that
they're getting to that quiet part out
loud aren't they
but they're not willing to show the
truth to the american people
because folks there are american people
out there that are much more concerned
about the depth herd trial they're much
more concerned about tom brady rather
he's actually retiring or he's not
much more concerned about that kind of
stuff
than they are about their way of life
because frankly that's what happened on
january 6.
it wasn't just an insurrection
it wasn't just counting
the votes that were certified from the
states
no it was not just a joint session what
happened on january 6 is they tried to
destroy your community
your church
your schools
you know the public schools and the
public roads that you hail
oh we have we have great public schools
in our neighborhood or we have shitty
ones either way
those public schools
you think they would have survived if
the constitution would have been torn
down
you think for a minute that state
governments would have survived the
united states constitution being
overturned
you think that is what would have
happened no
the american people need to watch
and they need to listen what these
[ __ ] tried to do
to our country
it wasn't just about the certification
of the 2020 vote
it is about taking our democracy down
it is about undoing the voice of the
people
they know that's their enemy
eight million more people voted for joe
biden and let me tell you something not
all of those 81 million who voted for
joe biden love him
they just knew the threat
that was knocking on the door from the
[ __ ] dummy in chief
and they sent him packing to mar-a-lago
but like kyle rittenhouse he just can't
stop his [ __ ] whining i can't get a
job i can't do this i can't go anywhere
boo [ __ ] who
[ __ ] boo [ __ ] who
you lost
pack your [ __ ] and go
but they haven't they haven't left they
continue with their coup attempt
and maybe just maybe with these
january 6 select committee public
hearings
the american people will open their
[ __ ] eyes they will watch the
hearings and know the truth
that it wasn't just the election they
were trying to overturn they were over
trying to overturn
your way of life your little cozy life
you suburban white people
in suburbia
it was not going to be the same
your little your little local government
and county government
that protects you and your your nice
cul-de-sac
your state government which affords you
different tax brackets
the federal government that provides you
ways
to manage your money
so you feel like you're middle class
that was all going away
your little school that you send your
children to
that you think is the best school ever
that was gonna go away
you think the state governments would
have survived
come on give me a break if the united
states constitution is shredded and
thrown in the fireplace of the toilet
and flushed down the [ __ ] toilet you
think the state constitutions would have
survived
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that was the whole point
they know what's coming they know
why do you just the same way they know
what's coming
with common sense gun safety they know
what's coming
they know eventually they can't blame it
on dildos back doors in porn
they've done the good guy bad guy thing
for a long time and that's [ __ ] they
can't do that they can't they're not
even saying those words anymore
they almost get booed off stage
we're gonna watch a video today of a
teacher who was shot twice in the uvalde
elementary every single [ __ ] one of
his students in his classroom were
murdered
and they talk about backdoors dildos and
porn
the guy didn't kill
those children in that classroom with
porn he didn't kill him with dildos
he did not tear down the back door and
bring in the back door and beat them
over the head with it he murdered them
with a [ __ ] weapon of war that he
bought on credit they gave it to him for
free with 1700 rounds two of them to be
exact
the minute he turned 18. oh this is a
really great idea america
that's the america they want folks
that is the america they want that's the
reason why they were trying to overturn
our constitution
they know what's coming
they know the
majority ideology wants equality and
equity in this country
they know that
they see it as a threat
and the constitution the thing that they
carried in their pocket for so long as
conservatives all [ __ ] every last
[ __ ] bit of it
if you ever in your life have claimed
that you were conservative
you were either completely 100 percent
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] or you did not
understand what the republican party was
trying to gaslight you with
one of the other
one or the other
you won't convince me otherwise
but here we have a hearing
one of the most pivotal moments in
american history
actual [ __ ] news
real news about to happen this week
news that's bigger than any [ __ ]
super bowl
any goddamn [ __ ] basketball game or
nba finals
way [ __ ] bigger
we're about to find out what the actual
seditionists plan to do on january 6 and
how they were going to overturn your
vote and take over your government and
tear down your community tear down your
way of life
we're going to find out the entire
country is going to have the opportunity
to know
whether they tune in or not that's up to
them i guess but we should put it in
front of their [ __ ] eyeballs
just like the johnny depp amber heard
[ __ ]
so if you have the capability out there
to clip off tv off my broadcast hell you
can clip off my broadcast and air clips
everywhere post them everywhere
it's important that everyone see this
even if they see it in snippets the most
important snippets
because it seems like this first
presentation there's going to be some
bombshells
there's going to be some very important
information that is going to drop on
thursday
we don't know what it is we can only
guess
it's going to give you probably more
insight into what even the doj knows
about some of the seditious conspiracy
that has already been charged and
recharged with superseding indictments
on the proud boys and the oath keepers
which it seems kind of funny
that the proud boys and the oath keepers
are both tied to one man
during that day
and that one man seems to over time over
history had a direct line
to grandpa poopy pants the cheeto dust
mobster donald trump the former guy
himself
stodger rhone is i'm gonna call him near
stodger roane
probably had a line probably had i don't
know i mean it's hard to tell
maybe that's what the burners were for
[ __ ] i don't know maybe we'll find that
out
yesterday we seen the proud boys
with the leader enrique tario
charged in a superseding indictment with
the same charges of the oath keepers
we also see a video
um released months ago but resurfaced
yesterday again around the interwebs
and the twitter sphere the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
of tario and stuart rhodes meeting in a
parking garage to plan for the very next
day when tario wasn't even allowed in
washington dc at the time
even in the video they mention it
what vehicle are you driving do they
know a vehicle do they know you're here
oh the boy they better not find out
you're here
they say in the video
and there's other people in that parking
garage who have not yet
been scrutinized
like the oath keepers and the proud boys
which i'm sure it's coming
maybe they're cooperating who knows we
know that tario has a history of being
an fbi informant or an informant for the
federal government
anyways
but all this ties back
to one [ __ ] the one [ __ ]
that was gonna benefit from the
constitution being torn up and thrown
away in the trash
one
one [ __ ]
who wanted to be dictator who wanted to
be king the manga king
of the united states america
and these deluded dumb [ __ ] these ninka
poop nazis
we're willing to go along with it
including including you at fox news you
[ __ ] cowards
sean hannity tucker carlson ingraham get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you were terrified of what was gonna
happen you were terrified that you knew
the truth
texting mark benos get him to stop get
him to say something hurry hurry it's
bad it's gonna be bad for us
always looking out for number one you
pieces of [ __ ] that's why they're not
gonna air this they're not gonna air
this because if they air the truth on
fox news
if they actually attempt to air the
truth on fox news can you imagine
how much viewership they'll lose
they've already gaslit their audience to
believe that somehow the january six
select committee is illegitimate even
though the constitution lays it out
these [ __ ] idiots who claim to be
constitutionalists and say constitution
every other [ __ ] word
have no idea what the [ __ ]
constitution is or what it does and what
power it affords which branch of
government you dumb [ __ ]
but they're about to find out
we are almost
to the find out phase of the [ __ ] around
saga
for the january 6 select committee two
days away
and we are going to air those hearings
right here
on youtube
we are partnered with midas touch you
know we air our broadcast every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central on our youtube
twitter and twitch
now i've had trouble with our twitter so
today it's on gabe's twitter yesterday
it was on mine i
get to get a fix and i'm not sure what's
going on
twitter is not connecting something
maybe they maybe it's the deep state
maybe it's elon musk i don't know
but we also simulcast for the midas
touch facebook page you know we are
proud partners of midas touch all the
mind is mighty out there
so thursday for the special coverage for
the prime time hearing and ever hearing
that is going
to be
public
we are going to live stream
on midas touch youtube and their
facebook
so go over the youtube link is
on youtube right now
we're going to keep continue to share
that link for that broadcast you can set
your reminder over there for that
broadcast we are going to air one hour
before
the hearing starts we're gonna have
special commentary
from the legal af team for the midas
touch podcast team
and many others
are going to join us
for the hour before and the time after
the hearing
and maybe some time in between it
depends on how the hearing plays out
but you are not going to want to miss
this hearing in our coverage
we will be playing it in full plus
commentary before and after so go over
to the midas touch youtube channel find
that link go to the midas touch twitter
page their facebook page
set your reminder for that hearing on
thursday again we will start our
coverage
at 7 00 p.m eastern an hour before the
hearing and i know that benny thompson
will gavel down almost the second
of eight o'clock
is when the chairman benny thompson will
will gavel in the hearing he does not
[ __ ] around he gavels in almost exactly
on time every single time
so please join us for that coverage live
streaming coverage again we'll have
plenty of commentary before and after
the hearing
from the legal af team from the minus
touch podcast team and many others in
the midas media network and beyond the
midas media network
we will also be bringing in some
characters and some personalities and
some brains of analysis that you will
know well
so please
please join us go set your reminder on
the midas touch youtube channel
for the january 6 hearing
on thursday and again we will be airing
every single one of the hearings all six
of them we know of six of them now it
looks like that's how many hearings
are going to be scheduled rather they're
the morning hearings of the primetime
hearings we will be airing front to back
every single one of them
so do not miss that you want to follow
us on youtube as well
so go subscribe to the youtube channel
and also follow us on twitter at toni
michael's pod at the tony michaels and
that i am gabe sanchez
you will find all the links there for
all the hearings and broadcasts that we
send here's the here's the thing about
some of these broadcasts some of these
broadcasts overlap our live broadcast
every single day no worries no worries
we are going to manage
to broadcast our our podcast the same
time so we will just do the the coverage
during our time
and then what we'll do is we'll cut out
the two hours
that we normally broadcast live for the
tony michaels podcast and we will
download it on apple spotify and google
so make sure you go over there
and you subscribe to those channels as
well
as well
thank you for joining us we have a ton
of new listeners here it just gets more
and more every single day there's so
many of you i can't i i used to do i do
shout outs but there's so many of you on
facebook and youtube and twitch i really
appreciate all all the listeners being
here
please be kind to each other in the
comments we welcome
we will welcome fox news viewers folks
oh i can't wait i hope i hope there are
a ton of fox news viewers that tune into
our broadcast because fox news won't air
it
don't you i i'm i'm in i'm in large
large hope of that that's what i'm i
really want to make sure
is that even fox news viewers have a
place to come view the january six
hearings
so they know the truth
i think that's what we need to have in
this country
there needs to be some plucking heads
out of asses in this country
you know the old annual cranial syndrome
we need to get rid of that we need to
help the aneocranial syndrome you know
head up ass
head past syndrome
we need to
we need to make sure
that we're helping that out uh we're
gonna have gabe sanchez joining us at
the bottom of the hour we're gonna surf
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
but let's do this let's take a quick
break
and we will be right back right after
these messages don't go anywhere we'll
be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome love and welcome back to the
show
for joining us
thanks for sticking with us here
we're gonna surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends you know here on the
tony michaels podcast the one thing we
do is we surf the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends we want you to know
exactly what's trending
and what commentary should be coming out
of those trends
that's right we want to give you
straightforward honest to goodness
commentary no holds bar really [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them man we ain't gonna hold back
here
so if that's the kind of commentary that
you want you are in the exact right
place if you're a new listener so please
please subscribe to the youtube channel
so you don't miss a thing here on the
tony michaels podcast
also follow us on twitter you do not
want to miss anything over there for the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
you know what there is so much trending
this morning and yesterday was so much
training but the one thing i want to
show you
is um
speaking of the trump fund you've seen
the commercial and the last break the
trump fund
crying victims that are trumpers
we have the murderer
kyle rittenhouse going on tucker
carlson's show the white nationalist
tonight show
talking about how he can't get a job and
[ __ ] and he can't walk around well boo
[ __ ] who buddy boo [ __ ] who
let's go watch that video
and let's go surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you have reached the shitless roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
and boy is
kyle rittenhouse trending for um a
whining he's such a whiny little [ __ ]
these [ __ ] [ __ ] on fox news these
these
these [ __ ] macho machismo tough guy
types
these ball tanning [ __ ] man
crying crying that he can't he can't go
to texas a m and then he tried to
[ __ ] you know we talked about this
yesterday where he lied on [ __ ]
charlie kirk show about going to texas a
m and then this [ __ ] and then
this
this [ __ ] says i'm gonna go to a
community college that community color's
like no you're not no you're [ __ ] not
that someone had some um tweets on it uh
gabe sanchez
good morning gabe how are you good
morning
boy it's going to be a tough week but i
want a
britain house thing it's going to be a
lot of stuff this week but it kind of
goes into this fox news you know white
marvelous crying whining being little
little punk ass [ __ ] to be quite
honest because
does this whole charade on tucker
carlson and we find out this morning
that sean hannity and tucker carlson are
not going to carry the january 6
hearings prime time history making
[ __ ] news
why would an organization like fox
news cover that
why would fox news do that right we've
already seen text messages that have
gone to meadows
from laura ingraham
and sean hannity
so
why would you put on display
the possibility
that more
kind of uh
evidence is brought forward by the
committee to say these people were
actively talking two meadows and the
inner circle about how to handle january
6th as a pr control team that would be a
little weird to be like well
oh the
committee's talking about how i text
mark meadows the guy who's being charged
with the contempt of congress possibly
because he won't give them all the
information about me and his let me just
imagine just being on like
streaming and commenting on the actual
hearings that are happening they mention
your name and go oop up and
and we're going to commercial right
right right what are you going to do i
mean when you commit sedition it's hard
to cover that sedition i mean right you
know but if you control a network
then you might as well control it by not
airing it right right so where do you
what do you think out of mind you know
where do you think the right wing's
gonna view this stuff though do you
think that there's gonna be because
there was talk that some of these
right-wing trader tv cable news networks
were gonna actually uh stream this stuff
and then give commentary over top of it
talk about how it's lying hoax and all
you know yeah basically say all this is
all even though they're under oath like
it's right yeah it's a [ __ ]
congressional hearing there's perjury
it's a big george soros set and all of
these people are just
doubles they're just actors that are
pretending to be these people
that are republicans who come in under
oath
and actually give their testimony so
what i think is gonna happen is either
one they comment on it and it's just
gonna be clips and they're gonna they're
just gonna cherry pick moments and say
how
that's not true
or this was totally misleading
or this was exaggerated now when it
comes to the testimony they might not be
able to play with it too much but with
the presentations that they do they
might cherry pick and and complain about
those because those aren't under
that that's not a witness that's that's
not right it's just laying out the
evidence and the facts that they've
gathered so i wouldn't be surprised if
they dissect over the weekend like
they've got a team they i guarantee
they've got a team that is watching the
content as it happens live on thursday
they will have a team of interns
breaking apart each of the sections
based on the topics then by friday if
not the weekend they will have segments
that are talking about how the whole
trial
based on this first day
is is moot like it doesn't even doesn't
even matter it's don't worry about
watching it go tan your balls exactly
they're they're gonna say we watch the
first day for you and we can tell you
exactly how this is gonna play out and
they're gonna say this there's no need
to watch the rest of them exactly right
don't listen to your friends don't
listen to anyone who says anything about
january 6 committee hearings and how it
was sedition
just listen to us
and we're going to tell you right now
that it's not even worth it because it's
all a bunch of
[ __ ] i mean we can actually change
the narrative here i believe that right
i believe us as a country can change the
narrative just like we changed the
johnny depp nerd i mean that whole
narrative got turned on its head whether
you believe it or not that whole
narrative got turned on its head about
johnny depp through that hearing
regardless of what you think of the
outcome or or you know the length of it
i never watched a single [ __ ] minute
of it other than clips that i
encountered on social media and that's
what everyone has to be focused on right
like there's going to be a lot of
content a lot of [ __ ] content
with these hearings hours and hours and
hours of evidence of presentations of
testimony that are gonna be in the
public now what you have to remember is
you have to take those small little
moments and you have to get them in
front as many [ __ ] eyes as you
possibly can that is very very important
here that we create viral moments now
the reason why that is is so that the
majority of america can see the [ __ ]
truth that happened
yeah and yes they may only get a glimpse
here and a glimpse there and a glimpse
here like we did with the johnny depp
and amber heard trial but we have to
turn this narrative on its head because
they literally wanted to take away your
democracy they want autocracy that
that's the choice here
is they were choosing autocracy yep they
they were making that choice and donald
trump was driving that choice and i
think that's what we're gonna find out
because um um i believe jamie raskin
over the last few days has alluded to
the fact that hey
there's going to be direct evidence now
we've seen yesterday gabe that um and
we've had dakota adams on stewart
rhodes's estranged son and tasha his
estranged wife on the show here and
interviewed them and talked to him about
stewart rhodes who was the founder of
the oath keepers and dakota has even
given us some insight into the militia
and what the the mindset of the proud
boys he didn't know any of them
personally but he kind of knows that
right type of person that that militia
white nationalist type type person and
he's given us some good insight but
yesterday we seen that tario enrique
tario
was
indicted on a superseding indictment him
and i believe five other proud boys
what's the five total yeah okay so him
plus four that's right so there's five
total
uh including tario who met with stewart
rhodes the day before uh in a parking
garage january 5th
2021. um but we see that he was charged
in a superseding indictment which i said
a year ago that is going to be a key
phrase in these doj
um criminal trials is superseding
indictments because they're trying to
fish in
bigger fish
enrique tario and stewart rhodes are not
the big fish folks right they're not the
big fish now the thing is is there's a
guy and i i'm gonna i think his name is
stodger rhone i'm not sure
it's possible that his name is stodger
roan but stodger rhone if that is his
name individual [ __ ] bag i mean i'm sure
that's what it says the individual [ __ ]
yeah it says that on the birth
certificate right right stager rhone i
think is his name um
actually has ties to that day right to
that day to both of those groups two
those people who are now indicted under
this conspiracy to commit sedition yeah
it's funny because
that same guy who may or may not be
named stagerone
actually has had a ongoing friendship
with a certain person who wanted the
constitution overthrown right did you
know this this evidence
is clear as day
that they possibly could have had
personal communication between each
other now i don't know if that had
anything to do with the the [ __ ]
burners that were bought or people were
passing around the burner phones i don't
know i don't know but we do see we do
see a a documentary about this guy i
believe his name is don jeron
yeah there's a documentary film and
they're saying that some of that footage
may be part
of these hearings um which i wouldn't be
surprised by because you know stager
rhone
for
all of his uh
connections and money like he is
not that smart about certain things like
he's very willing to open up himself to
cameras and it's the
the narcissism and
uh egotistical
dodger
is someone that would not
turn away a camera if it was put in
front of them so
if in fact there are moments that were
documented about stagerone doing things
with others that might implicate stature
rhone and certain things that might be
considered sedition right wouldn't be
surprised it is funny though that this
guy star jerome that you're talking
about he was closely connected like that
day in that moment with the people who
are now charged all of them charged or
pled guilty to seditious conspiracy yeah
like a conspiracy meaning they had a
plan to commit sedition
right all i'm saying is that there's
fire
or yeah i mean it seems it's not it's
over there's fire there's fire i mean
there's fire
but if there's a lot of [ __ ]
smoke i mean if there's smoke then there
is one hundred percent star jerome
committing sedition oh if there's stage
around there's definitely a dumpster
fire you don't even need to talk about
the smoke right i mean stagerone is a
walking talkie
dumpster definitely committed sedition
and he used certain people
like the oath keepers and the proud boys
and others
to on the ready commits edition
martial law that's right and take over
you know i mean like you know he's also
the one that was uh
stager run was the one that was in
charge of the brook spelled as riot in
2000 which basically stopped the count
and that's why you know uh al gore the
inventor of the internet no longer was
in the running for the president so how
how far we come from the brooks brother
right to a violent insurrection that
killed police officers and be police
officers with american flags and i mean
at the blue flags it's [ __ ]
you can't even make this [ __ ] up folks
he's like look i'm gonna send people in
to cause a ruckus with these people
trying to count the ballots okay it's a
bunch of these preppy looking [ __ ]
right that's that's enough that i'll
that's enough that i need to do in the
state of florida as stagerrone now we go
forward 20 years
20 years tony and stagerone has now had
enough time two decades that's a that's
that's an adult length of time where he
has he has fully committed himself as
stagerone to think about what's the next
course of action in the event
that the election doesn't go their way
he goes well [ __ ] man i can't do another
brooks brother riot no one wants to see
that sequel what i need to do is i need
to do a completely new remake a
re-imagining
of this
this coup
and it needs to be done on a scale that
no one will ever forget and no one will
ever forget my name is dodger [ __ ]
rhone you know that might be a good
point that he doesn't really care if
he's charged with seditious conspiracy
as long as people know his name as long
as people legacy the guy's got [ __ ]
nixon on the back of his back
right right and he love he loves to be
known for that like he even does the
stupid nixon thing on the right exactly
i'm not a criminal but i am mr penguin
right that's [ __ ] weird it's [ __ ]
weird speaking of [ __ ] people who
want their name known this [ __ ]
oh my god it is so appropriate that this
guy [ __ ] whined and cried in court
what a what a [ __ ]
punch
[ __ ] these three [ __ ] here it just
white nationalist tonight here is
[ __ ] ridiculous that that that
someone would have this [ __ ] box on
so he could whine about not getting and
this is
this guy over on the right here this uh
this older guy on the right is his new
attorney
now for everything anyway is is
tucker carlson's a written house you
really need to you know sorry yeah yeah
yeah cause tucker carlson may start to
have an attorney on here every time he
has a problem written houses your
attorney
now
for everything that you could say about
uh rittenhouse's attorney in court right
the guy that you know helped so make the
case for why it was right right even
after even after he's like this kid
needs to go away and yeah he's like he
needs to move away change his name and
stop this well i think he even said he
even said hey the right-wing media is
going to take advantage of this kid and
i've been telling him this that they're
just gonna suck him dry right and that's
what they're using and i mean
and the thing is like
kyle rittenhouse should have listened
right now despite what you want to think
about the lawyer that is probably the or
written house
but the lawyer the original lawyer that
is probably the best
uh
advice that anyone could have given him
just go leave become
someone else well you know you know
there's a there's a good example of
someone who was under a lot of scrutiny
who won their trial casey anthony a lot
of people compare rittenhouse to casey
anthony not not the situation right but
the actual winning of the trial which
was uh unexpected and also uh just
slinking away
into the the ether i think she's changed
her name she doesn't even you know you
don't even know who she is or where she
is she might even you know i mean the
only coverage you get is if someone does
like a documentary or a special right
exactly but exactly and and it's only
journalists that probably have access to
her which is very limited indeed but and
kyle rittenhouse didn't take that model
that's what his attorney was telling him
at the time is to take that model he's
done the exact opposite and even in this
clip the the best part is he [ __ ]
about the media and i'm like dude you're
on the media right
he complains i mean it's like an arson
being like there's a fire there's a fire
and you being the person that started
the fire like this kid
you know he murdered two people wounded
the third right and then he's like
people are so slinked away and got away
with it right
but not only that but then he keeps you
know the very conservative ways the
media's trying to silence my voice
they're trying to suppress my voice
they're trying to limit my freedom of
speech it's like dude
the reason people keep bringing you up
is because you keep bringing yourself
right the conversation you keep going on
white nationalists tonight right trader
tv network you're doing don't worry usa
women's edition have you seen that [ __ ]
where they were trying to auction him
off or some [ __ ] how [ __ ] gross is
dude i feel so bad for his dog which he
brings up in this dog that was his
like i can't even dog
here i can't even go to the dog park
anymore i'm like dude i figured they
they planted that dog that was well he
talks about his dog in this one so i
don't know if the dog on stage was his
or her or what but
let's listen let's listen to what
[ __ ] this punk-ass [ __ ] has to say
well we're gonna make the media pay for
what they did to me they made it hard
okay okay all right all right but stop
no i'm not even two seconds into this i
didn't even have enough time to start
crying oh my god this [ __ ] guy
we're gonna make the media pay for what
they did to me what the [ __ ] are you
talking about what was that what was it
called uh accountabi the project
accountability accountability project
what was the one that he that he said he
was gonna i don't know
to make sure that the media was held
accountable he's been talking about this
[ __ ] for months well i mean these
right-wingers are raising money off him
saying this right oh yeah like that's
the whole point is they're going to
raise money off him saying this dumb
[ __ ]
he's not actually going to hold anyone
accountable because you can't you were
[ __ ] charged with murder you dumb
[ __ ] the [ __ ] media gets to report on
you
[ __ ] being charged with murder and
the facts that beared out in public
people get to speak on those facts that
are buried out in public regardless if
they made it into the triad or not you
don't [ __ ] you beating up women and a
video of you saying you wanted to shoot
people who were on the street that's
[ __ ] public knowledge we get to
comment on it you dumb [ __ ] there's
nothing in there's no defamation of me
saying kyle rittenhouse is a [ __ ]
murderer because you were charged with
murder you were talking about murdering
people on your [ __ ] tick tock account
you dumb [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] get out of here
and this whining and crying that he's
gonna hold the media accountable get out
of here if there's any if there's any
clue that media isn't held accountable
for their [ __ ] lies you're on the
show right there you dumb [ __ ]
this guy this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ]
guy for me to live a normal life i can't
go out into public
i can't go to the store it's hard for me
to go anywhere without security good
good we don't want you in public you
dumb [ __ ] you stay the [ __ ] at home yeah
stay the [ __ ] home yeah we don't want
you in public you're a [ __ ] danger
obviously yeah why would we want you and
we don't want you in public and by the
way and by the way oh i'm so sad i'm so
sad that everyone now knows who you are
because you murdered two people i'm so
not only that but oh man i'm so sad that
you got caught in multiple lies right
whether it was asu texas a m or blinn
college community college which
up until recently had 100 acceptance
rate which now probably has a
nine 99.999997 you mean just the
exception for him for murder just except
for public murderers even blind even
blind community college is like whoa
okay listen
i know that we're a junior college and
we're all about being a feeder school
for a bigger school like texas a m and
others like to get someone ready for
success in education
however
we're just gonna draw the line here i
know that we say a hundred percent but
legally right
we're gonna change that on the website
we just round it up right right right
yes [ __ ] [ __ ] box let's
let's continue to hear him whine about
how he's not a normal human being
anymore
doing basic things like taking my dog to
the dog park is difficult so
they made it really difficult to be
normal and they affected future job
opportunities to me i don't think i'll
ever be able to work or get a job
because i'm afraid an employer may not
hire me you know the two people that he
murdered i bet they'll never get jobs i
bet they'll never be able to take their
dog to the dog yeah they probably won't
be able to live normally because they're
[ __ ] dead
yeah i don't understand
what a you are such a [ __ ] [ __ ] cow
right
carlson is more mile having him on say
this stupid oh yeah well i mean tucker
carlson is a total stand for kyle
rittenhouse any time he'll have my he
had the documentary ready to go as soon
as the verdict
was was given he was ready to go with
the kyle rittenhouse documentary like
the truth behind the scenes
ready to release this like he was ready
he had the commercial [ __ ] ready to
go as soon as that happened do you think
do you think what they'll do is they'll
air written house content over top of
the hearings because like they can't
probably let's if we're going to not
tell the truth let's definitely tell
some [ __ ] lies oh oh 100 i'm i'm sure
they'll be like oh the same people who
were behind the january 6 insurrection
that antifa were the same people that
planted the gun on kyle ryden house in
the kenosha riots he was the one that
pulled the trigger for him like i
guarantee they're going to somehow
blame antifa blame someone else on how
the fact that kylo ren house is not
a nazi or a white supremacist or a
murderer despite the fact that there is
evidence him being with proud boys crazy
and other people that might say
uh your white supremacist or that you
committed sedition or that you gave
people of color
he's gonna sue us now well you know what
that's how court rules so if he wants to
come after us he has to show
on the show just to eat his [ __ ]
lunch
yeah it'd be great i would definitely i
would definitely have him on the show so
kyle if you're listening and people you
can tag him tag him on twitter to the
podcast i don't give a [ __ ] yeah let's
let's have kyle on clip this out and
tell him i'm sure
he could come on the show he could come
on the show for a moment as soon as we
start asking
[Music]
that's why that's why he only goes on
these [ __ ] trader tv networks that's
the reason why he showed up at turning
point because they're just they're just
tossing up softball questions right
they're like how hard is your life right
now right i mean even during the day is
it hard to walk your dog
even i just want to point out i i i have
two dogs and i would never
never in my life if i knew the other
person who was the owner of that dog i
would [ __ ] never go to that dog park
again i would say [ __ ] no i'm not
bringing this murderous white trash
nationalist dog to
like i'm not going anywhere near that
right i'm not letting my dogs around a
bunch of white nationalist dogs i know
that's how you treat others right and
how do you beat women you shoot murder
people why would i ever want to be
close to you or your [ __ ] dog because
i know
the same qualities that you have you are
now instilling in that dog and i feel
super bad for that dog i really do
i feel like that dog should be taken
away and should be a rescue because
another loving family can actually do
good to that dog as opposed to [ __ ]
i'm a murderous white nationalist
kyle rennhaus you know well the dog may
have white supremacy issues too i don't
know i don't know the dog i don't know
the dog i just know the dogs what do you
think the dog's name is adolf adolph um
it's probably not that overt it's
probably something you know
underlying
and i don't know i don't know like rake
hey right but he's got three of them
right right well yeah well i mean he is
or he's got four he's the fourth right
right right four the fourth rank right
he's the fourth right not the third one
the third one we've already seen we've
already seen right right right right but
this is the fourth one as i come here
come here fourth come here reich well
you know this guy going
anywhere um
and i i watched the video and i'm not
going to show it where he's like
shooting some kind of machine gun or
some [ __ ] some gatling type gun
and at a shooting range
right there and a shooting range and
then he's like yeah something about joe
biden won't take our guns or some [ __ ]
he looks he looks really really fun
yeah he looked really shooken up after
he shot the gun he looks like he's
scared kyle rittenhouse is the reason
why people now wear bulletproof vests to
the gun range right well at to anywhere
to like the grocery store right or to
school speaking of that did you see um
lee mcgowan put out a uh
a video about the nra and republican
talking points i know you've done a few
videos yeah um this one is fantastic and
i know our audience loves lee so let's
take a look at this video because i also
want to show you a video game
of the teacher who was shot twice in the
classroom
um by the
by the the
the second amendment gun nut
the the mass shooter in uvalde who
murdered 19 children because republicans
let him have access to guns
for nothing for no money at all he
actually put it on credit and he got
they almost they almost gave him the gun
for free and said right go commit a mass
shooting right right well that's what
they want i mean they really want gun
sales up and they want people to be
scared of mass shooters so that they'll
go buy guns so that's the whole purpose
mass shootings
uh gun manufacturers figure that's good
for business so they like them that's
why the nra promotes it they're like
outdoors back door well not only that
but you have to you have to remember
that when when these events happen
uh the news is gonna report and they're
gonna say what type of gun they might
even mention what type of ammunition was
used and they're like oh hey oh free
advertising guys [ __ ] bing bing bing
bing we win right well i mean yeah who
who wouldn't want to make sure that they
know the last successful mass shooting
if you're going to commit a you're going
to commit um bullets are best to buy
with this ar-15 look look at buffalo i
mean look at that guy look at the look
at the kid and yuvaldi i mean this you
know these gun nuts that's how they
think
uh but let's see what politics girl uh
lee mcgowan's take is on this
the shooting in uvalde tells us once and
for all that everything the right-wing
nra messages is wrong a good guy with a
gun stops a bad guy with a gun [ __ ]
there were dozens of trained good guys
there and they did nothing while those
children were slaughtered in their
classroom mandatory waiting periods
expanded background checks and raising
the minimum age for buying firearms
won't work
[ __ ] this kid waited until he turned
18 walked into a gun store and bought
two ar-15s and over 1600 rounds of
ammunition no one stopped him no one
questioned his motives he didn't need
training or insurance he didn't have to
wait three days or a month while his
history was checked sure he had no prior
felonies there was no restraining order
against him but he'd been publicly
threatening to rape people he had a
bunch of women turn him in for violent
and disturbing online behavior and yet
this troubled kid could just walk into a
store and buy a semi-automatic weapon
well guns don't kill people people kill
people sure people kill people but
people with guns kill more people faster
and more efficiently how many children
could this disturbed individual have
killed with a knife or a hammer or a bat
or a rock before he was taken down by
someone in that classroom or the lying
cowards from the uvalde police
department would have even wanted to do
it if he didn't have the pleasure of
blowing people away with a gun
especially that kind of gun and why
didn't the police engage him because
that kind of gun has no business in the
hands of untrained civilians the police
know what an ar-15 can do to the human
body and they wanted no part of it the
police were scared of that gun well
that's why we need to militarize the
police [ __ ] the ivaldi police have
their own swat team 40 of the entire
city budget goes to their department it
didn't make a difference they did
nothing for 78 minutes while parents
begged them to save their children they
say they were waiting for a key for
border patrol for more information they
can't get their story straight but while
they were diddling around and tasing and
handcuffing parents who were losing
their minds listening to their children
dying they were covering their ass and
protecting themselves but we have to
respect the cops defer to them trust
them [ __ ] they lie
police officers seem ready and willing
to use all types of force on unarmed
people across america but a real fire
fight even at 20 to 1 odds not so much
well my second amendment right says who
cares who cares what your second
amendment right says it was written over
200 years ago when these weapons weren't
even imagined possibilities you want to
tailor our laws to originalism to what
our founding fathers were thinking at
the time well they weren't thinking
about ar-15s and body armor and infinite
rounds of ammunition and they certainly
didn't write the amendment to protect
guns over children they put in well
regulated for a reason and it's about
time we stopped ignoring that part of
the amendment
ban assault rifles raise the legal
buying age instill a mandatory waiting
period do background checks insist on
insurance and training pass laws for
safe storage and hold people responsible
for what happens with their weapons you
have the right to own guns but we have
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and our rights
trump yours
your arguments are played out
they're done
we're done
thank you lee politics girl for that
video actually i i have been
in communication with lee about the
january 6 hearings and i think lee's
going to join us for a few of them i'm
not sure exactly which ones so if you
are i know we've got a lot of politics
girls
um
in in in the chat here so if you're lee
mcgowan politics girls fan please join
us for the hearings on the midas touch
youtube channel we will be streaming
every single hearing live um on their
youtube channel so go follow my touch
the link for the first hearing on
thursday is there we are going to start
an hour before gabe an hour before so
check those out but back to the uvalde
shooting that lee was talking about here
um
did you get a chance to catch the
and it's
kind of uh the shooting in evaldi tells
us it's kind of disheartening right um
the video well yeah
it's
you you do you know which video i'm
talking about the the yeah yeah
yeah you talking about the good morning
america video yes um it's kind of been
circulated around i don't think it's
enough um it's kind of long here so what
i want to do is go to a break but i want
to talk about it for a minute before we
do
because you've done
a couple videos on the uvalde shooting
about the nra
i think you have one coming out soon
about good guy bad guy lee kind of um
breaks down that argument in in part of
her video there
um
but really this
this interview with this teacher is
chilling um to know the truth about guns
in this country right and that it was
the [ __ ] gun it was the [ __ ] gun
and there is no good guy bad guy and he
lays it out clear
he lets the world know what happened
inside that room
which is what we need to know
you know i i would say under the parents
consent you know just like emmett till
if they wanted to show the pictures of
their brutalized children that were just
slaughtered with these weapons to show
the country
really what your children are up against
when you send them to school
because these [ __ ] gun nets these
second amendment [ __ ] think that
they get to own weapons and shoot anyone
they want
because good guy bad guy or hunting or
it's our right or we're the militia or
whatever the [ __ ] they believe whatever
kind of argument they [ __ ] right um
what it actually does the actual effect
that it has not not some kind of
[ __ ] thing where you're [ __ ] oh
my tv and i'm going to protect my family
and all this nonsense is [ __ ]
hyperbolic nonsense real life [ __ ] how
it shreds
how it shreds
your [ __ ] body parts how it destroys
little children's
i mean if it if it has an effect on
children like you know
children that are obviously much smaller
than adults who are obviously the
intended targets and use for this gun
especially in warfare
but you have to think of the people you
know these republicans these lawmakers
who try to say well i'm using it to hunt
raccoons i'm using the hunt [ __ ]
groundhogs if you shot that animal with
that [ __ ] gun it would be obliterated
that thing would [ __ ] tear it apart
and they're like well here here are the
scraps from my hunt it's like no you're
not using it to
to hunt these animals
you're using it to annihilate and kill
but the fact that you're using it as an
excuse is disgusting and trying to
justify it
can i tell you a story i grew up on a
farm i don't know if you know this but i
grew up on a small little hobby i think
you told me we had chickens when i was a
kid we had cattle and we had because we
had chickens um you know we had laying
hens so we had eggs in a box
um we didn't own any pistols we owned
some hunting rifles because that's what
they were used for was hunting wild game
like
deer
turkey um and also
shooting you know varmint like raccoons
or possums that would come and you know
risk your livestock whether it be
mainly the chickens because they were
the most vulnerable to some of those
to some of those varmints now
when we would go check eggs in the
morning it would be dark and the
lighting in the barn wasn't you know
it wasn't great it was like two bulbs in
the entire barn
and when you went into where the laying
hens were there wasn't a lot of room
between the wall and the boxes so you
couldn't get a rifle in there
and we didn't own a pistol we didn't
have a pistol there was no reason for us
to have a pistol
just wasn't a reason for it
so what we had to do is you had to go
check for possum before you went and
reached your hands in these egg boxes
right because you didn't want to reach
your hand in an egg box with a pissed
off possum in there you just didn't want
to do it or a sleeping one and wake his
ass up right
so what we did is we cut off the end of
a deer arrow right do you know what a
deer arrow is adiro has a point on it
that when you really stick something it
gets them good right especially when you
pull it back out it gets them real good
so we would we cut off the end of an
arrow and that's actually how we would
get rid of the varmint it's because we
couldn't carry a rifle in there to shoot
it even if we wanted to yeah so we would
stick if there was a possum in the box
we would stick the possum several times
with the arrow um
killing because we couldn't really chase
them out because that's not when they're
in a box like that if you kind of corner
them they're scared and they're very
violent and they're not gonna go
anywhere they're gonna back into the
corner hiss at you bite you whatever
so we would stick them and then and then
um after we got done collecting age
feeding the chickens feeding the cattle
then what we would do is go back in and
remove the remove the possum
um
but we this idea even this idea even
that you would have to have an ak-47
ar-15
to get rid of a varmint like a possum
because it threatens your eggs and your
chickens is absolutely [ __ ] stupid
right it is ridiculous it is absolutely
ridiculous to think that even a wild
[ __ ] hog
that you would need that you would need
a weapon like an ar-15 to take down wild
hogs what are you our deer what are you
talking about what are you talking about
we have not had ar-15s forever right and
they have not been available forever
right people have been using hunting
rifles to kill hogs and deers for a long
time
because if you really need more than
than six rounds in your clip you kill
wild game you are you don't need you
probably don't even need that hunting
rifle to begin with yeah this is all
this is all just talk right it's all
talk to avoid the actual conversation
that your right to own these weapons is
not absolute
it is not absolute for you to own these
without cause without background checks
without any kind of regulation that is a
bunch of [ __ ] you are not the
militia you you are not you are going to
be regulated
it just doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
it just doesn't make any sense and this
video of this teacher now when you see
it it is bone chilling this the the the
truth that he speaks in this video
because he does not hold back to his
truth there's a few things in it that i
even believe i'm like wow he might
regret even saying some of those things
because he says some things that he may
never be able to take back um but he's
dead serious about it and so we're going
to play it uh here
it is i think it's about eight minutes
long but let's do this let's go to a
break when we come back
uh we will we will go to
the abc news um of the teacher from
uvalde stick with us we'll be right back
after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lid loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
thanks for sticking with us through the
break
we've got a video i want to play here
for you from abc news
but i want gabe to talk about this
because he actually for the for the what
was that series um that he's done he's
done uh two so far one on the evaldi
shooting and one on the nra convention
that followed it and he's working on one
that's a good guy bad guy uh what was
that so tell us a little bit before we
play this video give us some background
on what you know and what you figured
out about what the police did what they
didn't do really what the shooter didn't
didn't do in the timing of this because
in this video it kind of lays out the
the timeline to give you a good idea
before the teacher speaks but man it
really seems like
this video
because i i felt like that the ivaldi
police have been hiding something but
this video the way that he describes it
might be the thing that they were trying
to hide when you get to the end about
how many of the children in his
classroom were actually killed i think
that is the thing that they're trying to
yeah so i mean like as people uh follow
this like when it when it broke you know
it what was it uh like 10
45
yeah it's my time we were we were on the
air we were in the last like 15 10 15
minutes on the on the 24th and
we didn't know what happened you know we
heard that there was gunfire that they
had contained the situation right that
was the reporter right they contained
him as what they had been reporting at
that moment
however what we find out as it was like
every day after the fact we were finding
out newer and newer details
which were telling us
that he was not contained
they said oh he came in through the back
entrance
and he also exchanged fire with
uh
the resource police officer that was on
campus turns out he did not exchange
fire turns out there was no actual
officer from the district that was there
on campus
they said you know there's a 12-minute
gap in time where he they he crashed his
car which was he just had it in a little
ditch
that was unaccounted for right and then
reporters wanted to know what happened
can you explain during the 12 minutes
we can't really talk about that right
now
so they said the back door was propped
open by a teacher who's going to get her
cell phone
turns out that the door was not propped
open
right
uh we find out that you know during the
78 to 90 minutes that the shooter was
inside the school
that
the police did in fact go in to get
um
students however it was their own
students and that's the other family
their own family they're like
i'm only going in for my kid and that's
it and we watched yesterday a video of a
parent who was like well if you're not
going to go in for all the kids then i'm
going to go in for right you had
teachers who were who were getting
uh who were getting detained
and put in cuffs outside the school who
wanted to go in and were complaining
that the police weren't doing enough now
keep in mind they were i think at the
end of it there are over 20 different
agencies that were involved in this
thing you had this
law enforcement right right you had the
the the school district uh police
officers you had the ivaldi police
officer which those two those two are
not cooperating right exactly and that's
the thing as these details have come out
you know they've changed their story i
you know it's over 12 15 times now
they've changed their story like it's
not quite adding up what's going on here
uh it smells fishy i mean i've sat on
the show before with you where i was
like i don't want this to be true but as
you know i think it was like a few days
after the fact
this is something where i said
i have a feeling
and i hope i'm wrong that a police
officer who went inside
[ __ ] up the situation either uh made
made the gunman more uh aggravated
instigated something uh accidentally
shot uh a victim by accident
and the whole time they've been trying
to figure like okay well if we don't say
this person was in there then we say we
can cover this up and cover that up and
as more details come out you're finding
that it was complete incompetency that
was running this operation you had
parents who wanted to go in who were
being detained you had cops saying that
they were going in but only saving their
own kids you have timelines that have
changed you find out and you'll find out
from i don't want to take away from from
what we're going to see in a moment but
like this whole situation
is
it is it is 100
suspect it is disgusting and we've we're
seeing that this whole thing
on top of the fact that
once the doj came in like we're going to
start investigating only two days after
the fact or so they said you've already
police in the uld school district police
said
we're good we don't need to we don't
need to contribute
this conversation this investigation
anymore which is like why wouldn't you
[Music]
why wouldn't you want to help out why
wouldn't you want to get to the bottom
of this and there's clearly a reason
because they [ __ ] up and did something
inside that school and i think you know
lie after lie after lie compounding um
you know eventually the truth was going
to come out where there was going to be
someone like this teacher and like the
mom that we listened to yesterday in
that report the truth was going to
reveal itself that hey
these cops may not have done what they
were supposed to right and when they
were supposed to and how they were
supposed to because as you pointed out
even in your segments and even on the
show here that these cops were trained
for this specific school for this
specific event it's not like this was
some kind of you know like oh well we
trained off-site they trained in this
school for an event like this now the
problem is and and i'm again not going
to take away from the clip is that you
can't really train for these events
that's not the thing
that's not a thing you can do really i
mean yes you can be prepared but you're
not going to know and he explains it in
this video so let's go to this video
from abc news uh this report with the
teacher let's watch this again it's
eight minutes here so hang with us uh
i'm gonna watch it in its entirety
i said
if i die don't let it be invaded
this morning arnold for reyes the 4th
grade teacher in room 111 at robb
elementary school telling his story for
the first time as he recovers in the
hospital from two gunshot wounds hit
during the horrific massacre that took
19 students and two teachers lives
it was our typical morning and um
you know we breakfast together it was
going to be a good day because it was
going to be our day of awards and
some kids in my class that hadn't gotten
an award
you know all year we're going to get an
award that day reyes says the children
were enjoying the end of the year
celebration and while some students went
home after the ceremony 11 from his
class stayed behind they were watching a
movie when all of a sudden gunfire rang
out the kids started asking out loud
mr reyes what is going on and
i said i don't know what's going on um
but let's go ahead and get under the
table
uh get under the table and act like
you're asleep
um as they were doing that and i was
gathering them
under the table and told them to act
like they were going to sleep
is
about the time when
i turned around and
saw him standing there the gunman
entering classroom 112 at 11 33 a.m then
making his way into 111 through a
connecting door opening fire reyes shot
twice a bullet hitting him in the arm
and lung and a separate one striking his
back the 17-year teaching veteran
hitting the ground
i told myself
i told my kids to act like i'm their
sleep so i'm gonna act like i'm asleep
also
and i prayed and prayed that i would not
hear
none of my students talk
did you you you thought you were going
to die
yes ma'am
then while the gunman was still in the
classroom reyes hearing police nearby
according to law enforcement seven
officers were in the building by 11 35
a.m they took gunfire and retreated
reyes says a child in the connecting
classroom 112 called out for help
one of the students from the next door
classroom
will say an officer we're in here we're
in here
and then uh
but they had already left and then um
he got up from from my behind my desk
and he walked over there and he's over
there again
the gunman going back into room 112 and
firing more shots at 11 58 a.m children
from other classrooms seen evacuating
the school at 1203 pm a child from room
112 calling 911 dispatch where she was
by this point 19 officers were inside
the building but no one went in at 12 10
12 13 and 12 16 more 911
parents outside begging for police to
save the children
you know that there are kids right
they're little kids they don't know how
to defend themselves you said you were
praying do you remember what
you were praying for what you were
saying
in your prayers i prayed the lord's
prayer i praised my hail mary reyes says
eventually he heard officers come back
telling the gunman through the door they
want him to come out to talk that they
don't want to hurt anybody but then
silence again
more 9-1-1 calls including from reyes
classroom but it isn't until 12 50 p.m
one hour and 17 minutes after the gunman
entered the classrooms that border
patrol busts in killing the shooter
after that it was
just bullets everywhere and then
i just remember border patrol saying
get up get up and i couldn't get up did
you feel abandoned
in that moment by police by the people
who are supposed to protect you
absolutely
after everything
i get more angry because
you have a bulletproof vest i had
nothing
i had nothing
you're supposed to protect and serve
there is no
excuse
for their actions
and i will never forgive them
i would never forgive them how many
students were in your classroom when the
shooter came in
11 students
so
the shooter killed every
single student in your classroom
yes ma'am
that's when i got you thinking you know
this family lost one
this family last week
i lost 11 that day
and
i joined my parents said
i'm sorry
i tried my best
of what i was told to do
please don't be angry with
reyes says no training could have
prepared them for this even though the
school had extensive protocols he says
laws have to change
it all happened too fast
training no training all kinds of
training
nothing sets you ready gets you ready
for this we trained our kids to sit
under the table
and that's what i thought you know
at the time
but we set them up to be like ducks you
can give us all the training you want
but it's uh
bundles have to change it won't never
change unless they change the laws
reyes says he doesn't think he can ever
return to a classroom but he's making it
his mission to honor the lives of his
students and two of his fellow teachers
the only thing that
i know that i will not let these
children
and my co-workers die in vain
absolutely i will not
i will go anywhere
to the end of the world
to not let my students die invade they
didn't deserve this
nobody in this world deserves
this kind of pain
no mother nobody
deserves this
i will go to the end of the world
to make sure
things get changed
and it was also really important for mr
reyes for all of you to know that those
two teachers who lost their lives his
friends his co-workers eva morales and
irma garcia he says they were awesome
amazing educators and he wants the
parents of their students to know that
they too
tried to do everything they could to
protect them so he says yes you heard
that it's his mission he wants to see
change he really wants to see the legal
age to buy a gun raised he thinks that
will go a long way and also i just want
to send out
my love and thoughts and prayers to him
because he's going back into surgery
today he's already had multiple
surgeries he has a very long road to
physical recovery mentally i don't i
don't know that he knows
well he kept saying over and over again
please let the parents know i did
everything that i could he did not have
a bulletproof vest the others did
and there's so much more to the
interview that we could not share
it's uh it's heartbreaking um and i i i
think um
you know the country needs to watch
every single one of these interviews
they need to hear these stories as
gut-wrenching as it is as chilling as it
is
to listen to the teacher who was shot
twice who couldn't protect his students
i mean
there was nothing more that he could do
besides let them hide under the table
and
we're supposed to believe that in this
country that we cannot
we cannot
prevent
a
18 year old kid from hand getting two
firearms 17 rounds going into a local
elementary school which he went to
school
too by the way so we knew the inside of
the building somewhat
and to slaughter children that were
hiding underneath tables because
that was the training we we we really
think we really think that the the
quote-unquote word of hardening schools
because that's all it is is words
it's words because we've hardened
schools that back [ __ ] back door was
locked it was not propped open those
that school had protocol
that the police are more of an answer
that giving money to the police are more
of an answer
like 40 percent of that [ __ ] town's
budget went to the goddamn police
to prevent this from happening and they
weren't even willing to enter that
school now i believe it's because they
didn't want to be killed because they
knew what this weapon would do to them
just what it did to this teacher just
what it did to those children
slaughtered them ripped them to shreds
i mean it's not surprising right we've
talked about it before like if you yeah
you could train for the hypothetical
right the hypothetical training doesn't
put your life actually at risk right so
when you actually do have a shooting and
you have to respond that split second
decision of am i gonna go in and save
these kids like i've been told i should
do
or am i gonna hold back because me as a
human
i'm afraid which again is totally
natural totally natural to say there's a
gunman inside with an ar-15 and a
handgun and possibly other weapons and
they're killing people
do i want to go in guns blazing
and get killed myself
right well i mean but you take up the
job that's what you do
you go in
and you accept you sign i'm gonna serve
and protect these people
and
when [ __ ] push comes to shove
those cops stood by outside watching
watching a massacre unfold
and potentially going inside and making
it worse
even though that they were prepared even
though they had training back in august
of 2020 even though they went through a
hypothetical situation just like this of
what they should do
and what do they do
they let people die
well minus margie points at a really
good point here she says i repeat they
want to harden our hearts
so we'll just move on no no no we cannot
move on just like just like the teacher
says there we can't move on we have to
keep
going yeah it is it is
important to keep pushing that there be
change um and we do not need to listen
to the nra and the ted cruz the the greg
abbotts of the world that that want to
talk about turning our schools into
prisons to keep our kids safe that is
the most [ __ ] ridiculous thing i have
ever heard in my life i have no idea how
we got in a position in our country
where the
where even even a slight slight
percentage of parents are like well
uh we can't have we can't prevent guns
from getting in the wrong hands but we
can definitely we can definitely put our
kids into prisons it really is and the
other and the other thing too is like as
the teacher he's there's like
my job is during the eight to nine hours
these students show up to school
i am their i am their guardian i'm the
person that their parents have entrusted
to protect
so for him to say like i feel like i
fail them just let them know that i did
my best like that
that was the hardest part of that
interview
despite the fact that he
was shot and then witnessed these
children be slaughtered and then have to
feel guilty because he could he i mean
like you know there was nothing he could
do
well yeah he's gonna have to live with
that for the rest of his goddamn life
but also the fact that you've got that
nine-year-old student who has to take
the blood off
of her dead classmate
and off of his dead classmate and put it
on to their body
and say
i've got to pretend like i'm dead and i
said it i said it before one when that
when that segment where that news came
out
like
i could not imagine having the foresight
or at least being any sort of level of
preparedness to say i need to take i
need to take blood off this classmate
and put it on my body to make it look
like i've been shot and i'm dead right
she has to be hardened right 11 year old
girl has to be like margie said it has
to be hardened to look at her dead
friend's body take the blood off her
dead friend's body and put it on her and
play dead harden herself right for
combat for war for battle she was
watching a [ __ ] movie she was being a
kid stop it stop it with the nonsense
that we can't we can't do something
about this it's absolutely ridiculous
pluck your heads out of your asses and
and let's let's stop this fox news
trader tv gqp nra [ __ ]
yeah it's enough of this stuff we don't
have to listen to these [ __ ] fascists
we don't just like just
you know fox news is trending speaking
of trending and sweetie tweets and
trinity trends
fox news fox news has made this country
a war zone right not classrooms it's not
it's not just classrooms right not just
hospitals it's the insurrection it's not
every everything they have made the us
of a
a [ __ ] war zone where students were
children who are who are nine ten years
old have to think i gotta put blood on
my body to survive
for people to say
it is what it is uh we lose a few
million people here or there right with
you
whatever carlson was telling people go
out and and be combative with people who
want to wear masks you know right i mean
they say oh we're the choice party but
we can we're going to harass you when
you're wearing a mask like you don't
know why that person is wearing a
[ __ ] mask
they're sick yeah maybe they're trying
to be conscious of the people i mean we
find out the miami herald i was reading
on my phone during the break that the
florida had under counted of course
coveted cases and deaths failed to get
test results a state audit has now
said which is unsurprising when you've
got people like ron desantis trying to
say oh we're going to be fine we're
going to come over covid it's going to
be totally fine we're going to open
everything back up you don't have to
wear a mask don't do this and millions
of people across the country have
or a million people have now died due to
covet over a million right well they
don't want you to know that either like
fox news desantis greg abbott it's the
ted cruz it's the back door banned porn
and dildo [ __ ] right they don't want you
to know about the deaths they don't want
you to know about the insurrection they
don't want you to know the truth about
[ __ ] assault rifles or assault rifles
and weapons of war in this country they
don't want you to know the truth about
that so the best thing to do is just
shut you up and that's why they're
trending this morning now our partners
might just touch tweeted this last year
we made a hundred and eighty four
thousand eight hundred and fifty four
dollar
tv buy with this ad the ad that that
they got below here on fox news
this is this is how despicable the fox
news wouldn't even take the money
everyone's like oh box news is greedy
no folks it's not just money that's
driving that's driving their motivation
here it's to gaslight their audience to
get their audience to believe nonsense
and [ __ ] disinformation and
misinformation lies fox news refused to
air our ad
now they're refusing to air the hearings
entirely hell they probably won't even
do accurate reporting on some of these
school shootings and like the shooting
in buffalo tucker carlson went on and on
and on about how the the right-wing
manifesto was a left-wing what are you
talking about it was clearly a
right-wing manifesto
but here is the ad um because you know
this
this ad unfortunately or unfortunately
is gonna
i'm probably let me get it set here is
gonna it's gonna be relevant for
for the foreseeable future folks our
democracy depends on you engaging not
just with this january 6
but
acting on the information by going to
the ballot and getting more people to
participate in the election in 2022 the
midterm there's 81 million people
there's 81 million people we know that
still believe in democracy out there
that are willing to vote we need to get
those people to show up to the polls and
whatever it takes even it's to show them
the truth well fox news ain't gonna show
them the truth because they want to
suppress the vote they don't want
america to know the truth that the gop
has betrayed america
i'm proud of the officers i worked with
on january 6th
they fought extremely hard our worst
nightmare really come true an attack on
american democracy right here in the
nation's capital i experienced the most
brutal
savage
hand-to-hand combat
of my entire life i received chemical
burns to my face that still have not
healed to this day i just remember
people still swinging metal poles at us
and they were pushing and shoving they
were spraying us with uh you know bear
mace and pepper spray they were all
shouting at us calling us traitors it's
been very difficult
seeing
elected officials and other individuals
whitewash the events that day or
downplay what happened as an american
and as an army veteran
it's sad to see us attacked by our
fellow citizens
[Music]
midas touches responsible for the
content of this advertising
so fox news wouldn't air that because
you know it shows it shows the truth why
would they
right now we're going to get more of
this truth and a deeper dive than even
this video could give us yeah any than
any uh video could give us um and it's
going gonna start thursday we're gonna
air this coverage this special coverage
from midas touch youtube channel
uh me and gabe are gonna actually
the tony michaels podcast is gonna do
the production of the live stream so you
will see me you will see gabe you will
see other personalities uh streaming the
truth because that's what that's what
the american people need to to find out
is the truth right now again there's
gonna be a lot of content
but
you know gabe you know a lot about
technology and clipping things and
social media you've done you've done
i've worked for big tech right and
you've where you've done pretty well
putting out little small clips like yeah
and instagram you've had some success
with that um do you think because we
watch the i i think we talked about this
yesterday on the phone privately
the depth herd trial right that's kind
of the model here i believe you know the
thing that can the good that can come
out of that [ __ ] absolute dumpster
fire of that trial and their
relationship is to show the country
what the model is to get the word out
about about a an event and about a large
piece of content because folks
if if no one would have actually aired
that big piece of content like from
gavel to gavel they did right with the
depth her trial they wouldn't have those
little moments that you found on social
media they wouldn't have those moments
we're gonna have those moments with
these hearings and it is so important
so important that you share that you
show it that you share it around because
eyeballs mean everything everyone thinks
social media is fake and it's all you
know hyped up and you know who cares how
many retweets and how many views
folks this is going to matter
this is going to matter how many people
are viewing these videos how many people
are viewing these clips and some of the
most important moments that are going to
shock even me
even me who is very optimistic that
there's going to be information that we
have
that we can't even predict right what's
going to come out of these hearings
but the america needs to see it your
your brother your nephew your cousin
your uncle your aunt your sister your
sister-in-law
anyone who is not paying attention to
these types of things will sit through a
15 20 second video that is going to show
exactly what they were trying to do to
our way of life our democracy and our
constitution in our country it was an
assault on all those things and there
are going to be moments little tidbits
15 20 30 seconds that are gonna be
sprinkled throughout this hours of the
hearing that can be spread around social
media and it is up to you not just up to
you to go engage in the ballot engage in
these elections but folks this is the
moment where it's time for you to share
these clips and time for you to spread
it around social media as i like to joke
around is like herpes
because it is up to us to get this in
front of eyeballs and get these people
to know
to know what happened
with their own eyes their own ears and
have it in their brains just like the
depth heard trial there is a narrative
in this country and the narrative is
well is is the insurrection really that
important yes is it
we need to say have an answer to that
yes
it is that hell
yes it is it is that important and they
need to know the truth so it is it is up
to all of us
um to to make sure that we share this do
not hold back when you're sharing stuff
on social media make sure you're sharing
uh all the relevant clips that you find
we'll be posting a lot of clips now of
course we'll be airing the entire
broadcast on gavel the gavel even
commentary before and commentary after
so please spread that around as well i
know i know not as many people are going
to view the whole content as a whole
yeah as they are in these little clips
but but it's important to understand
that we also have to have those bigger
pieces of content to pull those clips
from because they have to be authentic
they have to be genuine and that's how
we are going to create this genuine
authentic storytelling of what happened
and why they wanted to overthrow our
constitution why they wanted to take
down our government
it's a it's a conspiracy to commit
sedition folks
it's right in front of your eyes
most people don't even know this gabe i
think i've told you this story before
and i may even told on there i had a
friend of mine you remember when the
story broke about the the former gay
um
he was chewing up documents and he was
flushing yeah yeah
right they were burning them sure
anything he could do to get rid of
evidence right
especially paper evidence because yum
yum you know copy paper tastes good
apparently i know right it's not as
greasy as a big mac or a bucket of kfc
but maybe maybe a taste that maybe he
had chicken-flavored yeah i mean who's
to say he didn't put a little you know
right spicer or a little sauce on him
maybe maybe maybe he he let it sit in
the bottom of the chicken bucket for a
day or two before he ate the paper i
don't know maybe he orders chicken
flavored copy paper i don't know
but here's the thing when that story
broke i was talking on the phone
with a friend of mine
average guy good job middle class wife's
a teacher everything's cope setting has
a family you know everything's good
right
he's not dumb he's not stupid he knows
how government works he knows how it
works and i and it's this story was a
couple weeks old and i brought up the
story and he said what do you mean you
mean the people who went into the
capital were burning documents in the
campaign i said no no no no no no no no
i mean they might have been they might
have been yeah could have but the
president of the united states donald
trump was chewing up documents spinning
him in the toilet flushing stuff down
burning them shredding him he's like
holy [ __ ]
this is a guy who's not not dumb he's
not he's not stupid he just did not hear
this story the story did not enter into
his vision or his hearing until that
moment and that is what is so important
about this next month
is that this story these moments have to
be in front of as many eyes is
absolutely possible and that's why gabe
fox news is saying no we're not going to
air this because they know the
ramifications oh yeah
i mean they are
they are complicit in this
sedition right
you know conspiracy to commit sedition
they are
complicit in this whole thing whether
it's pushing the big lie and saying how
there's a bunch of fraud and voter uh
election fraud and things that are
happening you know uh suitcase are being
brought in and uh you know a permanent
marker is being used all these bs you
know answers which which was something
that uh stager rhone was pushing
after the election before january 6 to
to show doubt
in the election
right and so you've got the fox news
newsmax oh and all that [ __ ]
right-wing [ __ ]
pushing the idea
that the election wasn't fair it wasn't
safe it wasn't how it's been all these
other years this year was different
because we had a bunch of people trying
to cause
fraud
they're the same people that have sown
doubt in any other situation whether
it's mass shootings
or it's the economy or it's covid
you know it these are people
that are complicit in these acts against
the country right like i would even say
that those things they've done are
conspiracy to commit sedition because
they were going against the best
uh the the betterment of
of the country
they're putting lives at risk for their
own
financial gain
for their own
narrative they want to push that we have
some breaking news and
apparently senator thune has his view on
uh assault rifles just what we're
talking about just what we're talking
about here listen this isn't very long
listen in my state they use them to
shoot prairie dogs and you know other
types of varmints and so i think that
there are legitimate reasons why people
would want to have them and
i think the challenge you have already
is that there are literally millions of
them
available in this country so the nra
tells me that there's legitimate reasons
like killing prairie dogs and varmint
you are such a [ __ ] bonehead that the
gun manufacturers because let's get this
straight senator through thune is
simping for a handful of families in
this country that have the ability to
manufacture these weapons and push them
out on the streets for profits pure
blooded cold-blooded murderous prophets
is what and and soon i'm sure if you go
back and look i'm sure he's getting he's
gotten his cut oh he's gotten his i'm
sure if you looked at opensecrets.org
you'd be able to find money that was
coming his way absolutely but the other
thing is you brought up your story about
you know the chicken coop and this
actually reminds me
so we in our in our suburb that i lived
in uh in in chicago
uh and also downtown
uh possums were like savage
they [ __ ] went to town because of all
the garbage right but they actually got
to a point where they were chewing
through the plastic garbage bins right
so you mean like the roll ones yeah the
roll ones that you would like put on the
street and stuff like right right so the
city would come by and yeah unless it
was metal you had no way to protect it
because what ended up happening is you
would go down the alleyway and you would
see a hole in corner hole in corner hole
in corner of all these garbage bins all
these plastic garbage they would chew
through that [ __ ] because they realized
that the garbage contained a multitude
of uh you know meats and food
yeah vegetables whatever it was just
scraps
and uh my neighbor
ended up
we ended up we had a we had a um like an
airsoft gun kind of thing and i had
other i know other people in the
neighborhood that had it too that they
would use it
to scare the opossums away
from
the garbage cans i didn't need an ar-15
to [ __ ] shoot this thing i needed to
shoot the fence or shoot nearby it
a little little airsoft pellet
to scare it away so it would run away it
wouldn't want to come back right because
here's the thing it was not it was not
safe no matter how you wanted to protect
it again unless it was metal the plastic
was was ruined they tried to replace
them it happened again replace them
happen again so then people started
coming up with their own ways and one of
them was buying an airsoft gun and just
shooting the fence when it was near or
shooting the outside of the container
of the of the garbage bin for it to
crawl like just scatter off
you don't need an ar-15 you don't need a
handgun you don't need anything of that
sort of that caliber of that magnitude
that would just obliterate a child's
body
to do the same
for a prairie dog
well i it
again this is [ __ ] ridiculous that
you would need an ar-15 to shoot a shoot
any kind of varmint right in the first
place this is really stupid um so stupid
in fact speaking of varmint um kid rock
is trending
speaking of marmot tucker carlson look
at this this is his official tweet here
tucker carlson originals let me let me
tell you how christian tucker carlson is
let me tell you how how how far off the
deep end these [ __ ] idiots have gone
he he censors it here but he says never
met a [ __ ] quite like kid rock
yeah i'm sure you haven't
um i guess this is why i didn't even
swear couldn't even swear he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] um this is i'm gonna show this
video now i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna
give this uh credit that this tweet
sucks but i think this is why kid rock's
twinning i'm not i haven't watched this
clip so let's see what the [ __ ] this
says we'll probably turn it off before
it's over but let's let's try it
how many shots does grandpa get you got
some meaty bass in there come on baby
look at that a lot of pressure okay i
want to remind everybody you see you see
kid rock here he doesn't look like he's
um
i don't know what the word might be
classy i guess i mean you know i'm not
how often have they been hanging out
because this is not if this is a new
clip this means that they've already
done interviews together right where he
can you imagine can you imagine someone
like tucker carlson who is a fish dick
elite um no
hang on there was an interview there was
an interview he gave with uh ben shapiro
where he said there is no crime in our
neighborhoods because we live in nice
upper class
uh wealthy communities right right that
is the guy who is now telling others
common people
how they should feel about the elite
right well speaking of elite speaking of
elite kid rock did you know gabe that
kid rocked it's all [ __ ] did you
know his persona's all oh yeah yeah he
he comes from he comes from a wealthy
family i mean this guy this guy is a
total [ __ ] fraud and he's only really
had
one or two decent songs that the one was
sheryl crow
picture i think it's called and if
you've ever heard him sing it live you
know the guys that was when they were
dating right i don't know but the point
is this that if you ever watch go watch
a live version of him actually singing
it live without any kind of distortion
or them changing his voice on a board
holy [ __ ] the guy is total [ __ ] he's
total [ __ ] the only reason why he is who
he is is because this persona that he
was able to afford by his is you know
his silver spoon in his mouth it's shown
here by the [ __ ] guitar island on his
pond right now let's go to the interview
here let's see what these look at this
look at this he really looks like [ __ ]
doesn't he now does he put the did he
put their glasses on to appear like
um he's got you know what he looks like
he looks like garth like he's trying to
look like garth
yeah from uh from
uh he's gone full on wayne's world
that's right that's right i like his
long hair and a hat i like the hat
though we the people you know the the
old american flag i'm american i'm
patriotic but let's listen to the
unpatriotic [ __ ] he says probably
redneck paradise
okay i can't stand the music i'm gonna
do that thank you thank you for stopping
that really appreciate it um let's see
oh here they are here they are yucking
it up with the guns oh haha shoot and do
the see this this is why
uh thune makes a good point i mean look
look at the absolute necessity of tucker
carlson shooting into the water that is
an absolute necessity game that you must
have when you are a gun owner because i
don't even shoot a gun
and the only the only guns i was ever
trained on was when i was a boy scout
and it was a rifle
it was a 22 rifle and a shotgun right
and uh this looks like shitty form
okay well i wanna i wanna i wanna tell
you that that tucker carlson here looks
really uncomfortable he really needs to
tan his balls more before he holds a gun
like this in the first place i mean
really honestly it's but but that's the
necessity that thune's talking about is
shooting a rifle into the water here
with tucker carlson he's like ha ha ha i
can't even i can't even believe i can
hold a gun like that
oh it must be fun to really
i'm just like you ha ha ha look at this
this guy is [ __ ] crazy oh my god why
do they like this rube like even kid
rock why would kid rock even hang out
with this [ __ ] rube
i mean i'm not i'm not a kid
but what is he trying to shoot is he
like hey look there's a bunch of you got
some bass in that which by the way
you've got some bass that you put into
this body of water they didn't live
there before right you're putting the
bass in there in a lot of places it's
probably it's illegal to actually um
by a lot of state conservation
departments it's illegal to use firearms
to fish with um yeah you know well you
know that's beyond the point you see him
there and he's like i'm just shooting
him right there ha ha look at
hey you you me to cut this you need to
cut this clip oh yeah i'm gonna oh i'm
gonna we need to make fun of that [ __ ]
it's kind of like that you know the ted
cruz uh clip where he's dribbling the
basketball and he hits himself and his
tan balls yeah that one yeah that's kind
of i know that
i mean talk about a [ __ ] right
right [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
this is oh it's so gross i'm not even
gonna play any more of it i can't i
can't do it i can't do it i appreciate
it i think the people watching also
appreciate the fact that you're not
going to play this i'm not going to
actually i'm just i'm just disgusted
it's so oh my god
where do you where do you think they
were tanning their balls after do you
think they went on to the no it was
probably it was probably
put your feet up in the air thing they
probably i i would imagine that gotta
generate
that documentary it looks kind of
ominous well i bet i bet kid rock
actually has his own ball tanning booth
or something i'm sure they got ball
tanning booths right they say i'm a man
on the outside or some [ __ ] yeah yeah
you go to like a little uh you know a
little like country fair you know with
those common people country fair with
them them common folk that tucker
carlson knows not a goddamn thing about
let's see what else is trending uh here
we got about 15 minutes left here on the
broadcast um let's see what else is
trending here there there's uh chuck
grassley is now trending uh rupert
murdoch of course is trending now but we
have rudy trending
but it's for sports i don't think it's
rudy giuliani let's go to the trendy
trends here is it football i yeah i'm
not sure
i'm not sure you know prince um is this
is would have been his 64th birthday
people are celebrating that today and
the artist formerly known as prince or
prince as you know him uh let's see the
predator movie's dropping
oh yeah i'm excited to watch that are
you really i'm going to probably i'm
going to probably watch that tonight
okay does it come out today i
well i don't know i i i don't normally
go in it looks good it looks i i have a
feeling we can do non-politics for a few
minutes all right just a moment just too
many people
yeah yeah let's let's let's wipe the
slate clean tabula rasa
looks like it looks like august 5th gabe
is gosh
you're way off okay we got to get out of
this thread before we
lose gabe here and then
the broadcast um
again kid rock is training youtube
premiums trending on taco tuesday um
gabe's favorite taco tuesday
is trending um
let's see what else do we have here
applebee's is trending i don't know if
that has are they serving tacos now is
that why they're trending this is this
is
applebee's has a decent happy hour at
least they didn't when i was in college
oh now
yeah this is some kind of viral tic tac
or something someone made a date and
you'll have to go go to the tweety
tweets and trendy trends to watch that
one um i want to get back to a few
videos here
um that we have let me see if i can find
them because there was there was some
stories yesterday that that possibly we
missed did you see the marjorie taylor
green video now we talked about well we
talked about um about her not being on
her set do you remember that and you
said no no no there's actually
there's she actually has a real set that
she's invested in which that has like
isn't great but it's still you know
something right it has like a curtain
behind it or you know something of that
nature but you've seen yesterday there
was a video out of milo yiannopoulos do
you remember this guy you remember milo
yiannopoulos yeah so apparently this guy
um is an intern for her or something is
that correct or he's been appearing for
her and then there's a video i think you
might have sent it to me or i sent it to
you i was like what is this vile [ __ ] oh
no i i sent it to you and i was like
jesus [ __ ] christ
no that's what it was yeah
yeah he was in he's interning for her
this
can you give the audience if they don't
know who milo yiannopoulos is yeah
former breitbart writer editor whatever
uh still piece of [ __ ] he was gay back
then
and now he's no longer gay he says he's
straight and he's opening a conversion
therapy clinic which is i think the clip
that tony's gonna show
um he was validated on shows like
um
uh
um wow why am i blanking on his name
right now uh well you know bill maher
bill maher right so
yeah so so i'll tell you that because i
watched that interview live i actually
went to watch that interview live and
here's why because i really didn't know
who milo yiannopoulos was until that
point oh wow and really honestly the
bill maher as bad as maybe bill maher
may be now at that point
when he let milo you novelist come on
and speak that's when he lost his book
deal he had to go back to [ __ ] europe
i mean there was a lot of [ __ ] that
happened to him because bill maher
basically said hey here's this
right-wing nut job who's convincing a
lot of people of crazy ass [ __ ] yeah no
one knows about it yeah no one knows
about it and he he basically gave him a
daylight he was uh uh
bannon's right-hand man yeah right he
was the person that was pushing these
ideas he was also like i am you know
he's like i'm dating a black man so i
can't be a white supremacist you know
right right i'm justifying right he's
like i'm a gay white man dating a gay
black man i can't be i can't be
homophobic transphobic uh racist
um you know he he looks at it and says
that i am this person that you should
totally trust because i'm telling you
how it is he's also the same guy that
until recently which was i wanna say six
months ago or a little bit longer when
the whole ivermectin stuff came out he
was talking about injecting ivermectin
and he had a photo on on parlor i think
it was yeah i think it was even he he
talked about how he was using horse pace
but it made him have diarrhea so he had
to
write something so then he was like oh i
got to inject it and then it was a photo
of the needle with ivermectin and then
like maybe his arm on parlor
but people have even on people on the
right have realized who milo is
and have pushed to remove him right they
don't write well because he is
he is
he makes the wackadoos look normal but
marjorie taylor green that wackadoo has
decided he is definitely her kind of
wackadoo
um and this is i don't know what event
this is but he's talking about his
conversion therapy because he claims to
be converted
um you know pray the gay away and here
he is talk just file that [ __ ] now
remember the reason why i'm showing you
this folks isn't because my unipolis is
relevant it's because he is interning
for a member of congress who committed
sedition on january 6 who is who is the
current nominee to take her seat and
remain in that seat where she holds no
committee power whatsoever this is the
guy interning for her remember this
but also
yeah go ahead how
how far he has fallen to go from this
person of of you know oh i'm someone
who's important i'm a writer for
breitbart i'm telling you how it is i'm
the real source of truth i'm being
interviewed here i've got a book deal
here
i'm touring campuses
now to be
marjorie taylor green's intern right
well and and and it makes sense though
because marjorie taylor greene is a
steve bannon semp right she's always on
her tv network which this is where she
got the idea to do her own show right
like to do her own traitor tv well that
or the matt gates's fire brand tv
they're all they're all going to do it
ted cruz has this trader tv they all
have their trader joey but let's listen
to marjorie taylor green's intern this
is her intern let's listen to what he
has to say some of the vile [ __ ] he has
to say
thank you uh so so this is this is a
conversion therapy clinic in florida uh
over here florida and we will be
offering uh electroshock treatment uh no
[ __ ] up your brain
to make you so that you're not
gay anymore well i want to point out
that the placard on the front of this
says uncensored
america and then down here over here on
the other side it says pray the gay away
because uh milo here not only is
marjorie taylor green's intern but he's
also open con conversion therapy
clinics in florida let's listen to what
he has to say about him
uh
what happens
um now i need this money
oh jesus because i've got to hire one of
those expensive ad agencies
uh and a better slogan because holy [ __ ]
man the grift is flimsy yeah i mean
this these people's grip is getting
flimsy and flimsier you remember you did
a joke about the the because trump went
on stage and said i'm gonna make hats
make america great again again and again
so i can just sell you more hats
like this is even flimsier than that
grift yep no i mean this is him being
like okay here's the thing also like
he's got a he's got a british accent
he's like oh listen i need to i need to
uh i need more money for this because
i've got this expensive pr agency that's
going to rebrand because the logo [ __ ]
if you took away the accent and just
tried to say his mumbling nonsense
nonsense
i guarantee people would be like
who the [ __ ] is this guy get him the
[ __ ] off the stage what is this weirdo
let's let's continue listening because i
want to go to the marjory taylor green
clip but let's listen because uh that's
the best really that i came up with i
also came up with uh if you like the
[ __ ] you get the shock
um
[Music]
it was suggested that uh that might not
fly uh people yeah that sounds that
sounds a little that sounds a little
ridiculous yeah
uh again you can't even parody these
people right like
dude i watched that video and i was like
what the [ __ ] how do you how do you even
make fun of this at this point like you
can't even you can't even make fun of
this
he took the joke right out of his
[ __ ] hatred and it's it's
it's
crazy to think
that this
this is an intern for a congresswoman
like that's where we're at with this
it's absolutely insane insane um i want
to see if i can find this picture
because i want to prove that you are you
are correct here and when you die there
it is well yeah but that's not the one i
want to show there is one where she's
she's talking about something specific
that i want to because
you know she was sitting you were you
claim that it looked like she was in a
hotel and here's i said it looks like
she's a hotel here's here's here's a
shot
of what it looked like when she was in
the quote unquote hotel as you say
because she's really close to the wall
she really doesn't have her microphone
correct there yeah and her logo is kind
of down in the corner but that's that's
you claimed uh no there's another set of
this mtg show or whatever and of course
mtg live is that what it's is that what
it is it's called yeah i mean she does
it on facebook that's where that's where
people are pulling clips from oh okay so
so facebook is allowing this garbage to
be yeah yeah yeah well you know
zuckerberg's got to make money somehow
right well i mean if they let us have if
they let us have you know
our show over on facebook why wouldn't
she be able to have hers i mean it only
makes sense it only makes sense it man
i'm just
you know i if it's like if i had a
producer here is there a specific clip
that you want to find or you just want
to go back there was a couple clips that
people were talking about and maybe
maybe ron's got him i don't know um
he's got those clips of because i think
he goes over he actually braves this ron
um and his team watch this [ __ ] like
front to back like they watch this
garbage to continue to to pump clips to
us so that way we can um and he actually
has the written house clip too here it
is here it is
i believe
yeah i think this is it here i think i
got it here okay
okay let's let's
let's see if we can
let's see if we can find this clip we're
three minutes until the end here this is
this is more like it
as far as engagement that's it there's i
told you she's got a little projected on
the back there it says mtg
right she has a double she has a double
logo here by the way because she has let
me remove our banner so people can see
she's got her little mtg live and then
she's got the mdg
on the back madrid taylor green hookbook
green
yeah but let's listen to what this
[ __ ]
this
pray the gay away interning
piece of [ __ ] has to say that's so make
sure that your tax dollars are helping
people in ukraine to defend themselves
but he stands ready to vote for all of
joe biden's gun control bills he's ready
to go ready to vote yes on that now
don't forget this is the same senator
republican senator that's been one of
those in the senate
she's talking about lindsey graham here
okay so so she's saying
basically in so many words and lindsey
graham is for gun control only if it's
not to send weapons of war to i don't
know like a war zone yeah that's what
she's saying she's saying lindsey graham
is voting to send
weapons of war to a war zone and and
he's considering voting against weapons
of war on our civilian streets
that's that's the boneheadedness here
he's also voted to confirm all of joe
biden's picks for his administration he
doesn't really have a problem with the
people that joe biden picks he goes
ahead and votes them on in remember when
president trump could hardly get any of
his people confirmed yes democrats stood
in the way and tried to block every
single one that's because they were
complete utter [ __ ] yeah i mean that's
why they're complete utter [ __ ] there's
no excuse for any republican to vote
against some of these picks that biden
had because they're not complete [ __ ]
they're qualified they can do the job
and joe biden picked him that's that's
the [ __ ] deal
like that's the whole point
we elect you to represent
us you dumb [ __ ] she's such a
she doesn't you're she's a fascist she's
a fascist she doesn't she can't
comprehend democracy she can't well
lindsey graham's not doing that he's
helping his friend that he's he served
in the senate with for years and years
he's helping him and making sure that
joe biden gets his people put in place
so they can radically destroy the united
states of america i don't think that's
what a republican senator from south
carolina should be doing
this sounds like projection oh my god a
republican that's trying to ruin the
united states of america right
i don't know
oh god ron and his team thanks for
watching that for us so we don't have to
holy [ __ ] can you imagine having to
watch that every day i mean i love our
viewers here coming every single day for
two hours yeah can you imagine having to
go over and watch that [ __ ] [ __ ] box
every goddamn day listen to her whine
and complain and [ __ ] and moan about
you know
why can't i be why can't i be a fascist
why can't we just be nazis why can't we
just have a nazi state the fourth reich
why
why can't we it's [ __ ] absolutely
sick disgusting and ridiculous now
gabe did you know this thursday i'm
gonna say this over and over and over uh
tomorrow this thursday
are you in 1080p i'm in 1080p i'm
listening i'm listening on thursday
evening we're gonna have special
coverage okay there is a there is a
groundbreaking hearing gonna happen in
the january 6th select committee now the
hearing starts at eight game but our
coverage starts at seven pacific
7 p.m pacific go to who's gonna who's
who's hosting this we the tony michaels
podcast is hosting what midas touch
special coverage
of the january 6 select hearings this
thursday is the very first public
hearing and is the prime time hearing
there's going to be a huge presentation
you already see the stories out about
that we'll probably go over that more on
thursday not in the lead up because we
will be doing our broadcast every single
weekday the same way we do them even
with the special coverage monday through
friday noon eastern 11 pacific
9
11 central nine pacific yeah yeah yeah
get the times right a lot of
broadcasters
it's a it's you know see the shining sea
you know just get to get get the time
zones right there's a lot of broadcasts
so
i did i did see some people ask about
seven seven is we are doing a
pre-broadcast show before it leads into
the actual training we will have an hour
of commentary you're gonna hear from
folks um from legal af podcast um from
the midas touch podcast the mizellas
brothers are gonna be there um we're
gonna have some other guests indeed uh
we hope to have politics girl in some of
the hearings and some other
personalities that you guys know and
love and want to hear from from their
commentary from the standpoint of and
we're gonna be announcing more of these
uh guests as these hearings tick on and
tomorrow and thursday as we know more
what our schedule will look like of our
guest but yes we will have an hour
before the hearing so go to the minus
touch youtube channel subscribe there
subscribe to our youtube channel do not
forget to subscribe to our youtube
channel you don't want to miss anything
here yeah but you definitely want to go
over to the midas touch youtube channel
and subscribe there the link
for the hearing is there it's also on
their twitter page follow us on twitter
i'll put it in the chat right that's
great yeah go ahead a sec go ahead and
put the uh the youtube link in the chat
for that specific hearing on thursday
again the coverage starts at 7 00 p.m
eastern time the hearing will start at
eight and i know it will start almost
exactly at eight because it is benny
thompson's hearing he is the chairman
and he is very very very
very uh
hellbent being on time as that gavel
will come down at eight o'clock um it
seems that there's going to be a 90
minute
presentation there might be a few breaks
in between i hope we get a few breaks to
talk about some of the stuff that's
being said uh so stay tuned and tune in
for the whole thing because
we will air the broadcast but during if
there are breaks we will commentate then
we will commentate an hour before and we
will commentate after as much as we need
to uh to bring in those guests for you
guys to get your commentary um that you
want to hear about the hearings uh there
i just i just put in thursday june 9th
at 7 00 p.m
uh jublin go to the youtube um set your
reminder for that hearing and join us
not just join us for the hearing join us
all week we will be here at our normal
time two hours every single week day
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific see i got it there
on youtube twitter and twitch
and simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page until that time tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking